boys it's a great idea to end this
celebration with one of i think your
greatest songs give it away
is a real crowd pleaser right is that
something you close the show with last
song of the night is it your favorite
song to perform that changes every day
um but it does not get old it's a song
that has been fun to play ten thousand
times without getting too boring here it
is boys give it away
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
then right now
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
is
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
do a little
[Music]
don't stop continue
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
give it away
[Music]
away
[Music]
yes
wrap it up
[Music]
be
[Applause]
wow
wow
holy mackerel first of all flee you got
to go on dancing with the stars you
would win the [ __ ] golden uh ball i'm
telling you and anthony i would imagine
when you're singing and you see flea
moving like that it inspires you you are
not lying i i saw a reflection to my
left and i thought somebody in the lobby
is getting down
then i realized it was flea